good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
live from waterloo station this morning
whether it's trains planes or
automobiles millions of us have had to
change our plans this week due to the
biggest rail strike in a generation that
started this morning there's also flight
cancellations and back injure backlogs
at airports and petrol prices at a
record high pricing some people
out of their cars all making travel very
hard indeed if that wasn't enough
there's the impending threat of other
public sector strikes as i said we're
here at waterloo station which is a
ghost town today with the war of woods
continuing between the government and
the rail union on today's show we'll
speak to both the transport secretary
grant chaps will join us very shortly
we'll also speak to the secretary
general of the rmt union that's mick
lynch
and will any labour mps join the picket
line it has been suggested they will
we'll ask the shadow chief secretary to
the treasury pat mcfadden we'll also
talk to the boss of ryanair michael
o'leary about the current crisis at uh
at our airports it's the longest day
tuesday the 21st of june
two high demands on pay the prime
minister's words as he accuses the
unions of harming the people they claim
to be helping by going ahead with the
biggest rail strike in a generation
i'm at leeds railway station where
there's an rmt picket line
the government says these striking
workers need to compromise they say they
want guaranteed job security first
i'm live at cardiff station here in
wales where more than a thousand train
services are cancelled today most of the
country completely cut off
you know the current cost of living we
know that you need to get paid but at
the same time
don't hold the public's ransom if they
feel they need to strike that's their
business and i support them
a warning of a knock-on effect on the
roads with increased traffic we're going
to keep you updated from the national
traffic operations center here in
birmingham
bags of trouble at the airports too with
one in 10 flights cancelled here at
heathrow yesterday
[Music]
so sorry about what's happening today
good morning welcome to waterloo station
as the biggest rail strike in a
generation gets underway this is one of
the country's busiest transport hubs but
things very different today as you can
see uh tens of thousands of rail workers
on strike and so really it's empty and
it's replicated right around the country
the prime minister says the unions are
harming the very people they claim to be
helping and as further strikes
potentially loom from other public
sector workers such as nurses and
teachers boris johnson says two high
demands on pay will make it difficult to
end the current challenges that families
are facing with the rising cost of
living the raelian in turn threatening
that the dispute could drag on for
months and months
these are the scenes around central
london just four and a half thousand
trains are running
out of a normal twenty thousand we're
expecting an awful lot of people as you
can see on the roads trying to get to
work trying to get themselves back on
their feet after two years of covered
issues and then if we look at what's
happening with the train stations all of
those trains there's a metropolitan um
london underground strike i should say
london metro strike uh today so uh
24-hour strikes so all of those trains
lined up as well these uh live from our
skycopter this morning
throughout the show we'll keep you up to
date with all the very latest travel
information for train travel around the
uk and which services are running and
when there aren't very many but we will
try and tell you what is going on we'll
also talk to our correspondents as you
can see around the uk
gerard tub is at a picket line
at a leeds station
excuse me dan whitehead is at cardiff
central station the impact of the
strikes on wales pretty much cutting it
off from england in addition to that if
you can afford to fill up your car to
travel we'll be looking at the impact on
roads becky johnson is at the birmingham
national control center and then maddie
is standing by for us
with chaos cancellations and delays
continuing at the airport she's at
heathrow this morning
grant chaps transport secretary is with
us not a very rosy picture is it mr
schatz
it isn't and very unnecessary as well
when it comes to these um strikes i uh
you know
i hear the unions say that it's about
pay i hear they say it's about job cuts
in fact there's a pay offer on the table
and the job cuts are by and large
voluntary
so it's unnecessary it's taking us back
to the bad old days of of uh of union
strikes and uh you know they've walked
away now from the negotiations yesterday
saying that they were going to strike
and uh calling off any chance of a
resolution
what are you going to do about it
well we're going to have to push on with
these reforms anyway that the railways
run in many ways based on rules which
were put in place in for example the
1950s and haven't much moved on so
they're not run in the interests of
passengers they're all sorts of very
very restrictive practices which carry
on and for example uh timesheets with
network rail have to be filled out in
many cases manually rather than on
computers and you know that kind of
modernization the types of things which
prevent uh modernization in in the way
that the railways uh up kept uh the
upkeep of the railways those things have
to change and we're going to push on
with that in any case and i see that
network rail
have written to the unions last night to
say that since they've come to the end
of the road and the unions have gone on
strike some of these changes will now
need to be uh implemented
yeah my point is what are you going to
do about the strike
well the strikes this week are a reality
they they've they've called these three
days of of strikes uh that
what we'll do in future though is make
sure that we've uh put some additional
protections in place for the traveling
public for example through
minimum service levels which is
something that we included in our
manifesto that would mean that on a day
like today a certain level of service
would still have to be
run
and through changes to allow for
transferable workers that's a much
quicker change that we can make and that
means that somebody who works for
example for the railway companies at the
moment or for network rail
could switch
to
for example carry out another role for
which they're fully qualified and
trained and provide more flexibility on
our railways so there are there are
things that we're going to do
uh to push ahead even though we don't
seem to have the cooperation of the
unions at the moment but as ever we want
the unions to uh come and resolve these
these talks have been going on for a
long time and there's simply no reason
come back today
okay come back to that in a sec we need
to be information rich because people
want to know what's going on so are you
saying that you are changing the law and
you're also bringing in agency workers
so this won't be a problem later on in
the week not quite no that's not right
nothing that we can do
this week would change the reality for
the strikes this week law changes take
time
we've always hoped not to have to change
the law because uh we've been talking to
the unions for a long time
over a package of reforms about 20
different areas of reform with network
rail and there's always hope we wouldn't
need to get to this point but for future
strikes
both in the uh in in this current uh
strike but also uh for other strikes uh
we're going to ensure that the the law
is firmly on the passenger side on the
consumer side when it's not a rail
strike
well one of the ways is through that
transferable skills or agency workers as
you as you call it another is through
providing minimum service levels and
there are a number of other technical
changes that we can make uh to union
laws to make sure that the public is
always protected i don't think it's
acceptable that people who've perhaps
waited for two years to get a hospital
appointment today may not be able to get
to it the kids who are doing their gcses
and a levels this week 17 public exams
they won't be able to get to in some
cases it's not acceptable to disrupt
businesses that are just getting back on
their feet and so we are going to take
steps to make sure that this type of
thing
is
you know less damaging in the future for
people
okay but how how are you going to do
that minister
uh well specifically changes through
secondary legislation and through
primary legislation which means passing
laws in parliament
okay what's the law going to say
well the you you mentioned about the uh
agency or transferable uh workers uh
that's a law at the moment that for
example if you have a uh somebody who
works at a terminal in a uh operation
center at network rail and is fully
qualified to work at the next terminal
at the moment there isn't the
flexibility for that person to be asked
oh actually for this afternoon can you
man this terminal over here it would
provide that kind of flexibility that
you'd have in any other business this is
this is a sort of these are the sort of
working practices that have developed
and been allowed to continue on our
railways uh because we've got quite
militant unions that we're having to
work with calling strikes on an
unnecessary basis telling their workers
that there was no pay rise being offered
when in fact the pay freeze from
coronavirus had already come to an end
and thanking people who had dished out
600 pounds per family 16 billion pounds
of taxpayers money by going on strike
the first opportunity that they've had
okay
what why aren't you rolling up your
sleeves and getting around the table
with the unions this week so that we
won't have another two strikes
well the employers are the people to be
round the table with the unions they
have done they've met with them on 60
plus separate occasions six zero uh
separate occasions it's always the
employers and the unions who have to
come to a settlement in these things
they're the ones with the technical
details they're the ones who uh
who actually have the mandate to do the
settlement as well so uh you know it's
always the case it's the employers and
the unions who get together on these
things
yeah but am i not right in saying that
the government is the only shareholder
in network rail it belongs to the
government the government sets its
funding um
you are involved whether you're saying
you are or not you're the transport
secretary it's your responsibility to
keep the country running why aren't you
rolling up your slaves and sorting it
out
well if i thought there was even a one
in a million chance that my uh being in
the room would uh help source it out
then i'd be there
network uh mick lynch who's the uh head
of uh
of the union the rmt um said last month
that he would never negotiate in his
words with the tory uh government
in fact uh government of course in every
single uh public strikers of course
ultimately uh
uh ultimately um the the the pay the pay
master behind it but we set a remit and
it's for the employers to
make the negotiated settlement and it
wouldn't help in fact it would actually
undermine the process for ministers to
walk in the room uh looking back at
every strike that i can see in the past
including why
what
because these are highly technical
negotiations they involve 20 plus areas
of reform which are required which are
extremely technical and that needs the
employer and the union to decide i'd say
this is a bit of a red herring uh you're
saying it because the unions and labor
have suddenly got together and said why
aren't ministers in the room i should
remind them that when there were
firefighter strikes under blair and the
unions were calling for ministers to be
in the room
it remained with the employers when
there were strikes by the post office
workers under brown and labor uh were
asked to be in the room the ministers
were asked to be in the room the then
labour government said that of course it
has to be settled via the employers and
the union so it's standard it's standard
practice yes indeed but it's standard
practice i'm just pointing out that
there is no role for ministers to
directly walk through i think what
you're asking for is for me to go back
to the sort of the bad old days of the
1970s whether then labour prime minister
harold wilson had beer and sandwiches
with them in in downing street and it
did not work out well i do not think
that that is the way forward in english
it's not working out very well today
either is it
not yep are you saying no no mr schaps
shops mr schaps are you saying it's too
technical for you to get involved
i'm saying the employers are the people
with the mandate they're the people who
need to settle okay
okay but but you
are the transport secretary you
represent the government in other words
ergo you represent the traveling public
and they for the rest of this week are
going to be basically at a standstill as
you said people could die as a result of
these strikes you need to roll your
sleeves up you need to get in that
meeting room with the unions and you
need to sort this out is what my viewers
will be shouting at their tellies this
morning
well as i've tried to explain to you
several times that is not the way that
industrial disputes are resolved they
never have been since the days of beer
and sandwiches at number 10 in the 1970s
and it didn't work out very well then
the way that re disputes uh need to be
resolved are always between the employer
and the employees the unions themselves
as i said the unions have called a
strike under a false pretence there was
always going to be a pay offer on the
table uh they took their members out to
strike uh telling them that there
wouldn't be by balloting in april before
uh the pay freeze have been unfrozen uh
nationally we've got a completely
unnecessary very very damaging um strike
they are hurting precisely the people
that they claim to be protecting because
white collar workers who can simply stay
at home use their computers log in by
zooms or teams will carry on as before
the people they're hurting are people
who physically need to turn out up for
work maybe on lower pay perhaps the
cleaners in hospitals and the rest and
it's very damaging of these unions i
absolutely deplore what they're doing
today and uh there is no excuse for
taking people out on strike under false
presences and that is exactly what okay
okay just because you've explained it to
me several times mr shap doesn't mean
that your point is necessarily valid i
go back to the point that the government
is the only shareholder in network rail
it belongs to the government the
government sets its funding how can you
claim not to be involved and not to want
to be involved and not being able to get
involved when that is at the exact point
you should be speaking to the unions you
should be getting around the table and
you should be sorting out this mess your
country has come to a standstill and
it's your responsibility
i i understand that you want us to go
back to the 70s and beer and sandwiches
with unions and ministers negotiating
all right it's just yeah it's just not
how it works
it's just not how it works
if you're saying that every time there
is a dispute
the what's required is for ministers to
personally go and negotiate the
resolution then why hasn't that happened
when there was a junior doctor's dispute
why didn't it happen when there was a
firefighters dispute why didn't happen
with
other disputes including for example
when the post office workers went on
strike you know as well as i do the
employers are the people with the
mandate the employers are the ones with
the technical uh details to negotiate
this this is a stunt which i'm afraid
you're falling for by the unions and the
labour party the labour party who won't
even condemn these strikes today and the
unions who only last month were saying
they would not negotiate with the
government and have suddenly decided uh
running out of uh things to say that
they'll suddenly call on ministers to
talk to them and walk in the room with
them directly it wouldn't resolve
anything in fact it would make matters
worse and that's why i'm not in the room
okay
you keep banging on about the 1970s
we look as though we're heading towards
a summer of discontent
hearing from the prime minister that he
doesn't want inflation busting pay rises
as a result of that we're hearing that
even criminal barristers are thinking
about going on strike we're hearing that
nurses are thinking about going on
strike doctors are thinking about going
on strike care workers are thinking of
going on strike teachers are thinking of
going on strike who is it that's taking
us back to the 1970s
well we're clearly having a a difficult
time along with the rest of the world
with inflation right now it's a global
phenomenon after coronavirus exacerbated
by putin's invasion of ukraine
everyone's going through the same thing
i don't think we'll end up there and i
very much hope we won't and in
particular in the area that i know best
on these rail strikes there's no need
for it because there are so many reforms
that are required that would make the
railway much more modern and run in
favor of the passenger that in return
for those we can pay a pay increase and
unlike the message from the unions in
this particular dispute we most likely
don't need to make compulsory job cuts
for the most part this will come through
voluntary in fact we've already had more
people come through voluntarily than we
could accept uh to leave the the
railways um so uh you know these these
are strikes being called under false
protectors i hope that in other areas
which i'll know about in less detail we
don't get to strikes as well and i think
after the whole country i mentioned the
16 billion pounds we put into protecting
the railway it's been the same across
the economy that's
000 pounds per rail employee i don't
think it's a way to thank people for
their uh for their hard-earned cash
going into supporting the railway by
then immediately calling a strike as we
try to recover from coronavirus
just before i let you go just to clarify
you're saying that if you were in the
room with the unions it would make
matters worse is that what you're saying
it's a stunt by the unions who could
settle this today they've had a pay
offer they know that these reforms which
they've been resisting for decades need
to go ahead these work practices that
prevent us from running a railway seven
days a week from treating sundays like
any other working day for example are
long long overdue railway workers are
fortunately well paid the medium salary
is 44 000 the average salary for a train
driver is 59 000 pounds that compares
with 31 000 for a nurse and the
government has to make that overall
choice of balancing pay across the
public sector fortunately railway
workers have been well paid it's at time
to get this strike settled and i do call
on the unions to come back to the
negotiating table and fix this thing
okay robust defenses as always uh i
appreciate that you've got a challenging
day ahead of you mr shaps we appreciate
you starting it with us here on sky
thank you thanks very much
thanks a lot tamara's here hi thoughts
morning kay well grant shaps and the
government they're very bullish in
facing down this strike they say it's
harming the people that it's intended to
help they say that it's on false
pretenses because the unions have been
made a pay offer what might that offer
be well mick lynch of the rnt union says
that they turn down what is effectively
a three percent pay rise two percent no
strings plus another one percent uh
linked to productivity there are some
reports that they may have been offered
something even higher they say that they
want more than that because their
members are grappling like everybody
else is with the rising cost of living i
think the question going forward for the
government is yes they can say this is
all the union's fault and that it would
achieve nothing by them getting around
the table with the unions if they're not
willing it would hinder them because it
would hinder them they say it would it
would achieve nothing um if they are not
willing to in the government's view be
reasonable because they say high pay
rise is only fuel high inflation but
what message does that send to the wider
public sector to teachers nurses
other transport workers who are not on
strike today but may go on strike later
in the year if they are facing inflation
nine percent now um scheduled to to
reach 11
and they're only being offered a three
percent pay rise in many cases after
many years of real terms pay cuts for
many in the public sector so and of
course the government can set channel
people's anger at the unions now but of
course i think in in the end i think
there's an awareness among many mps that
they they will be looked to to try and
sort this out and thoughts of winter of
summer of discontent
well i don't think grant sharps did much
to dampen that down he said look things
things are going to be tough the
government's message is that public
sector workers um do a very tough job
they do the people like railway workers
work very hard throughout the pandemic
even during the first lockdown and that
a pay rise is there they're not being
offered nothing but they're urging them
to take um what the government say is
reasonable but the transport workers
including mick lynch there you can just
see uh in our pictures um have said is
not enough and the picket line of course
that we indeed labor front benchers
we're told have been banned from going
on the picket line although the union
leaders have been saying that labour
should be supporting the workers in
their struggle to get higher pay
interesting what grant shops was saying
about changing the law
and and also bringing in um it won't
affect the it won't impact on the
threaten strikes this week but going
forward we're going to have agency
workers and the laws going to be changed
so that people can be moved around the
stations to do different jobs that's
right and it's being pointed out that
even in the 70s uh during of course
margaret thatcher's uh
the previous government's struggles with
the uh the miners and margaret thatcher
struggles with the mines in the 80s this
was never done agency workers because
there was a fear that they may be
attacked on their way in
grant chaps and the government have made
clear they're going to tweak the law
this week to enable
some agency workers to do some of the
work now of course you've got 50 000
people on strike today a lot of those
jobs cannot be done by agency workers
they won't have the right training but
the idea is that agency workers may be
able to provide a basic service and that
would be a real um a real sort of
crossing of a line many people think in
terms of the government's approach at
two strikes it won't help this week of
course but the idea is that it could
help it later in the year okay it's 7
22. if you're getting the 730 to
southampton from uh here at waterloo it
is running so hurry up and you can get
on that train uh looking uh closer at
the situation uh about what's happening
around the country though for you now
and the first of three rail strikes
planned for this week is now underway
the others are due to take place on
thursday and also on saturday the
strikes are affecting services across
england scotland and wales and people
are being told to work from home if they
possibly can
among others of anti-west coast and gw
rsa trains will run on a limited service
southeastern railway and west midlands
railway are also just two of the lines
that will be running a reduced service
at waterloo southwestern railway plans
to run two trains an hour to southampton
and basingstoke and four trains every
hour from waterloo to windsor and woking
the last london north eastern railway
trains are all scheduled to depart
before 4 p.m
in the north of england
trans pennine express and northern rail
have warned of significant disruption
and mercy rail will have no train or
replacement bus services on strike days
in scotland no trains will run north of
glasgow and edinburgh on strike days
with just two trains per hour running
between the two cities
and the vast majority of services in
wales will also come to a halt
to get the latest travel updates on all
train lines visit national rail
enquiries online and follow the sky news
travel blog and on mobile
we're also having hourly updates here on
sky news
now throughout the show we'll be looking
at the impact of the rail strikes on
real people trying to make ends meet and
talking to those striking about why
they're doing it and bringing you the
latest travel information as we said i'm
here at waterloo station and we have
reporters at major transport hubs for
you
gerard top is at a picket line at leeds
station uh dan whitehead is at cardiff
central station the impact of the strike
on wales is pretty much cutting it off
from england
if you can afford to fill up your car to
travel we'll be looking at the impact on
the roads too becky johnson is at the
birmingham national control center
and then chaos cancellations and delays
continuing as the airports uh continue
to struggle maddie is at heath rowe
let's start with gerard should we
gerrard is in leeds for us this morning
hi gerard good morning what's it like
where you are
well the station's still locked k uh
it's been locked up this morning opens
up in five minutes
but it's not going to be much fun if
you're trying to get anywhere in the
north of england today
by train northern rail um have the
biggest most effective blanket policy i
suppose you could say
don't travel is their advice um and they
say that from now until sunday because
of the knock-on effects on the days the
strikes aren't on a transpandin express
is saying it's going to be very limited
only travel uh if it's uh essential
they're also pointing out that today
there are a number of stations
completely closed on the line across the
scarborough um sema moulton scarborough
itself is shut
broth hull is closed and yarn uh up uh
in t side uh and lner as you were saying
all those trains leaving by um four
o'clock today well the last train from
king's cross to leeds is at five past
three this really is not a day to be
using rail for getting anywhere you need
to be
okay let's bring in dan standing by in
cardiff hi dan thoughts from there
well as you said k wales is essentially
cut off more than a thousand train
services across the country here
cancelled today on every day throughout
the strikes 85 percent of services
simply not running we're at cardiff
central station the main station here in
the capital just look at the boards
behind me here 10 departure boards uh on
the wall her every single one just with
a sign industrial action severe
disruption trains meant to start here
around 5 30 in the morning up into the
valleys so far not a single uh train on
the boards the situation in terms of
what is running in wales is there are
meant to be at some services from london
to cardiff a very limited number of
trains no sign of any of those
yet there is nothing west of cardiff
patalbert swansea millions of passengers
use the trains there each year simply
nothing in or out west of cardiff there
are no trains whatsoever in mid wales
there are no trains at all up in north
wales real disruption for the people of
wales if you're not in card if you are
essentially cut off there are a couple
well they're meant to be a couple of uh
lines running up into the valleys today
because they are not run by network rail
they're run by transport for wales so
they don't need those staff who are
striking but essentially pretty much
every service is cancelled we were
chatting last night to the passengers
getting home on those last couple of
trains one of those was ronnie santiago
a nurse who visits her patients using
the train network she's had to make new
plans to get to work today
because there's no train at all tomorrow
i'll have to ask my partner to take me
to work and i
i live in cardiff and
um i'll have to go all the way to
virginia for work tomorrow so he'll have
to take me there and then pick me up
tomorrow at have a seven in the morning
so it is it is actually affecting me
that's the situation from ronnie uh who
is an absolutely vital key worker having
to change her plans what was also
interesting though is there are a lot of
people who we spoke to at the station
last night not actually too bothered
because of course the pandemic has
changed the way that a lot of companies
are allowing their staff to work a lot
of people working from home given that
flexibility that perhaps they weren't
given before kovid 19 was around so they
can now simply work from home i was
chatting to some of the station staff
here as i say they expect some trains
from london not really convinced that
they're all going to run as planned
nothing on the departure boards it is
half past seven and the whole of cardiff
central station here in the capital of
wales empty
okay thanks a lot let's uh bring in
becky what's it like on the roads becky
yeah this is the national hub where they
monitor all the major motorways major
a-roads they've been gearing up today
for traffic levels resembling those of a
bank holiday getaway that's what they
were planning for there's extra staff
out and about we've got live pictures of
the road so i'm going to step out and
show you the situation on some of the
busiest roads if you take a look at the
screens behind me on the top left there
that's the m25 you can see already
cueing clockwise just near to the
dartford crossing uh the middle screen
on the top there that's the m6 that's
actually flowing pretty well just near
the junction with the m5 normally quite
a busy spot and then on the top right
there you've got spaghetti junction just
north of birmingham again flowing all
right a bit of a queue getting towards
birmingham but that's the picture and
all eyes on it really here because uh we
were expecting we were being warned of a
surge in traffic as people uh turned to
their cars instead of trains let me
bring in frank bird from national
highways here frank better or worse than
you're expecting at this stage in the
morning uh at the moment it's about on
profile for a normal tuesday morning so
we're quite pleased that people have
heeded our advice
so normal for a tuesday so not the
surgery expecting why could that be do
we think um you know we think that a lot
of people have perhaps chosen to work
from home the next four days are going
to be glorious so it's maybe an
opportunity to stay away from the office
um but you know overall we're pleased
that people have taken our advice we've
had
over a hundred hundred gantries warning
of potential uh congestion for uh since
thursday so you know quite a few days
for people to get used to it and
thankfully a lot of people are taking
our advice the people heeding those
warnings what about for the rest of the
week are there any particular days
you're worried about um on the uh on the
days when there are strikes so um
thursday and saturday but obviously as
well um rolling stock is probably going
to be out of place uh on wednesday and
friday so we'll be doing this operation
right the way through till the weekend
all right thanks so much for talking to
us frank so okay yeah frank's saying
actually pretty normal for a tuesday
morning could it be people are staying
to work from home has the weather made
people think they prefer to work from
their gardens could it be petrol prices
meaning people just can't really afford
to drive even if they can't get the
train we don't know but we will be
keeping an eye on it it could get busier
later if people think that they decided
to delay their journey perhaps thinking
that it would be particularly busy first
thing we'll keep you updated
okay becky thanks a lot what about
getting away from it all on a tray and
or a plane from heathrow maddie's there
what's it looking like there today
maddie
yes well if you are hoping to fly away
um the rail strikes will affect you too
because most airport services like the
gap express aren't running at all today
or are running a severely reduced
service like the heathrow express and
that will of course not only make it
harder for holidaymakers but also
airline and airport staff trying to get
to work and the tube network down as
well which takes you to heathrow and
that's the last thing we need because
there's been weeks of chaos now and just
over the last few days let me remind you
two days we've seen more queues and more
delays at airports and thousands more
cancellations
from easyjet yesterday and here at
heathrow one in ten flights were
cancelled after the airport asked
airlines to start um pulling back their
services so it could deal with the
backlog of baggage and we saw over the
weekend deb payne's sky correspondent
filming those mountains of baggage
building up so um there are still
problems here and what with uh the staff
shortages at airlines and airports and
the rail stripes check before you travel
is the advice and probably good luck
okay thanks very much indeed thanks a
lot i'm just looking at the board uh
behind me and it does look as though um
all of the southampton trains are
running from uh
waterloo this morning so if you're
hoping to get from central london to
southampton it looks as though you can
at least for now and it does say that
they're all on time
at meantime speaking to the programme
this morning the transport secretary
grant shouts he has criticized the
unions for going through with the
strikes but said it would not be helpful
if the government entered into the
negotiations mr schapp said employers
have the mandate to resolve the
situation
i i understand that you want us to go
back to the 70s and beer and sandwiches
with unions and ministers negotiating
direct it's just not it's just not how
it works okay
it's just not how it works
if you if you're saying that every time
there is a dispute uh the what's
required is for ministers to personally
go and negotiate the resolution then why
hasn't that happened when there was a
junior doctor's dispute why didn't it
happen when there was a firefighters
dispute why didn't happen
with uh other disputes including for
example when the post office uh workers
went on strike you know as well as i do
the employers are the people with the
mandate the employers are the ones with
the technical uh details to negotiate
this this is a stunt which i'm afraid
you're falling for by the unions and the
labour party the labour party who won't
even condemn these strikes today and the
unions who only last month were saying
they would not negotiate with the
government and have suddenly decided uh
running out of uh things to say that
they'll suddenly call on ministers to
talk to them and walk in the room with
them directly it wouldn't resolve
anything in fact it would make matters
worse and that's why i'm not in the room
okay
so the government is not going to get
involved it would make matters worse is
what uh grant shap has said the
transport secretary this morning as a
result we are entering a week of strikes
here around the uk let's uh put it to
the secretary general of the rmt union
mick lynch why we found ourselves in
this position hello to you mr lynch
thank you for joining us what an
absolute mess
well it's a mess created by grant chaps
and government policy now we could get a
solution to this dispute grant traps can
come to the table if he wants i'm not
particularly bothered but if he wants to
come to the table he'd be welcome as
long as he comes in a framework of
goodwill what he needs to do really is
allow the management of the train
operating companies and network rail the
license to get on with negotiating at
the minute he's dictating what they say
he's dictating what they can spend and
he's dictating that they must make
unreasonable changes in our industry
which includes for instance
closing every ticket office in britain
it includes last night's statutory
notification of compulsory redundancies
2 900
on track maintenance and it includes a
pay policy that's making people all
across britain poorer some of our
members have not had a pay rise for the
third anniversary now we can resolve
that if we've got a proper negotiating
framework but the fact is that grant
chefs richie souneck and boris johnson
are dictating the terms of this dispute
now they can either facilitate a
settlement or they can block one at the
moment they're blocking one they're
telling lies constantly they've just
told another lie
that i've heard on your program that
we've refused to negotiate i have met
every single transport minister that's
relevant to my industries the rail
minister the bus minister the maritime
minister about issues we will meet with
government ministers anytime night and
night or day as long as they come to the
table in a constructive approach
okay but you say that and you say that
grant shaps would be welcome at the
table but you're also quoted as saying
um that you wouldn't be seen dead
negotiating with the tory government so
which one is it
well i should that's just nonsense
i don't know where you got that from uh
whether you've seen me say that that has
just been made up by the tory press
office and it's being regurgitated by
various media outlets
i meet with them all of the time i've
met grant chaps i've met all that met
all of those ministers we will talk to
anyone that's got a constructive input
into the dispute or has got influence
over a settlement
why do you think grant chaps would tell
us on sky that he said that you said
that he said that you wouldn't be seen
dead meeting with a tory government why
would he say that if you hadn't said it
i have no idea you'd have to ask him you
might want to ask grant chaps why he's
used pseudonyms in the past to cover up
his identity i don't know what's
motivating the difference oh come on
come on come on i do know but i do know
that they have a strange relationship
with the truth including in parliament
and on the record and on the media
okay talk to me about what your message
is uh to the traveling public today some
who are children who will be missing
their exams could well have an impact on
their future some of them who need to
get back to work having two years of
covid and some people who could be going
to hospital appointments potentially
having surgery won't be able to do that
and could die as a result of these
strikes
well i think you've been dramatic that
railway workers that make uh
hospitalizations die we have to give
statutory notice
of two weeks before we take industrial
action preparations can be made we've
taken four weeks since the ballot
mandate was returned and we've been
available to negotiate a settlement all
through that time as we are today and as
we were up till half seven eight o'clock
last night my message to the travelling
public is that we're very sorry for the
disruption that's been caused we don't
want to do that we want to get a
settlement to this dispute but like
everyone else many members of the
traveling public are suffering from the
austerity imposed by the government both
in the private sector and the public
sector
profits are rampant uh dividends are up
shares are up the only people who aren't
making any money at the moment working
people around britain who are struggling
they're struggling in full-time work
taking state benefits and some of them
are having to use food banks we need to
get a settlement to that and the british
worker needs a pay rise they need job
security decent conditions and a square
deal in general if we can get that we
won't have to have the disruption in the
british economy that we've got now which
may develop across the summer
what would be your
uh advice
to other unions who are
potentially uh
considering ballot action balloting for
strike action uh as well would you
support them in that
my advice to the unions is to campaign
on the issues and ultimately if the
government and the employers do not
change their direction i believe that
more ballots of strike action are
inevitable and more action is inevitable
and what i would say to trade union
leaders and trade union activists is we
need to coordinate and synchronize our
campaigning so that we can rebalance
the inequalities in our society i think
i'm knocking an open door on that
because the trade union leaders across
the tuc and across britain are telling
me that they want to join this campaign
we had a massive rally on saturday
on these issues working people are
crying out for leadership and direction
the labour party can contribute to that
but it's going to be the trade unions
that make the difference in this
equation at the moment
what do you mean by synchronizing
we need to coordinate the action so we
need mass rallies we need people on the
streets we need protests in every town
and city in britain and if we have to
have industrial action we should
coordinate that industrial action so it
has the most effect possible
um we heard from david blunkett a labor
politician previously as you know
previously in the cabinet he said
you your union are taking us back to the
1970s
well he's talking nonsense he's out of
touch and he doesn't know what he's
talking about i started working in the
1970s are you talking about coordination
by
yeah but you're talking about
coordinating strike action with a number
of unions bringing the country to a halt
i'm talking about coordinating strike
action so that we get effective
campaigning so that british workers can
get a square deal off corporate britain
who are raking in the profits
the problem with inflation in this
country is people profiteering so if we
can get a deal with all of these
companies we won't have to have strike
action it's because we've been too
passive over the last decade or so that
workers have found themselves exploited
it's because of the lack of action and a
lack of coordination that's why british
workers are suffering it's why companies
can take advantage it's why we've got
fire and rehire right across this
economy we've got outsourcing and
precarious work so it's obvious that we
need coordinates
because we need to rebalance society
yeah but mr lynch the whole point of
coordinated action would be
i'm guessing to bring the country toward
otherwise why would you do it
no
no the point of coordinated action is to
get an effective negotiating
position at the table with the employers
you know i don't know what it is you're
suggesting are you saying that workers
should passively accept the reduction in
wages the stripping out of terms and
conditions extended hours and precarious
employment if we want a stable society
where people can guarantee their jobs
where they can look to progress
themselves uh in our society then we
need strong trade unions it seems to me
that all the all the media want to do is
spout tory lines so everything that the
trade unions do
we've got the five day week we've got
public holidays we've got holiday
agreements we've got pensions we've got
women's rights we've got uh equalities
laws all because of what the trade
unions do and have done through our
history we have been the most
progressive and democratic force in this
society and we can intend to continue to
do that
okay mr lynch i would also hope that
you'll be able to have a robust
discussion without name calling but
there we are tell me how much you're
asking for as a union what pay rise do
you want
well i'll negotiate that with the
employers you know the figures the the
the network rail figure at the time it
should have been settled was 7.1
i'm telling you if you let me finish
the network rail figure in december
should have been 7.1 and the train
operating companies between seven and
eight we'll negotiate on that there's
lots of ways to put value into a package
and we'll deal with the employers on
that basis
what would you accept
well i'm not going to discuss that with
you i'll discuss that with the people at
the negotiating table i don't i don't
negotiate on the street with a media
presenter because you you're not the
person negotiating with me so i'll deal
with the employers well negotiations are
not going very well are they and i think
the british public wants to know what's
going on so i'm asking you what the
union would accept
well i'm not going to deal with that
with you i will deal with the employers
we negotiate with them it's not very
respectful
to the employers if we're trying to put
together a package but it's not just
about money it's about the conditions
that our members serve under and it's
about their futures and it's about the
redundancies that we're faced with in
this industry that'll all form part of a
package and a negotiated settlement so
i'll deal with them on that and i won't
attempt to negotiate standing on the
pavement at houston
well i would have thought you'd be happy
to negotiate anywhere as long as you
managed to sort this out for your
members how much have you been offered
well
you know what we've been offered if you
read the press releases we've been
offered two percent
uh by all of the companies and there's a
further one percent available if we
accept all of the conditions including
the redundancies
and the stripping back of
conditions of service and that's not
acceptable to our people
i don't know what you've been offered
which is why i asked you because
according to some of this this morning's
papers you've been offered three percent
plus another one percent if uh other
guidelines are met so is it two percent
or three percent that you've been
offered as a baseline
[Music]
it's two percent we've been offered as a
baseline by both sets of companies
okay thank you for clarifying that what
would your advice be to
thank you i'm glad you clarified it i'm
just putting it to you that other people
are suggesting otherwise and you're the
man who in the know so i'm glad you
clarified that for me what's your advice
to rmt members uh on picket lines if
agency staff were going to try to get
through that picket line
well there aren't any agency staff
you can see behind me there's no agency
staff available agency staff can't carry
out the work of my members they're
highly skilled safety critical workers
working in engineering for railway
operations signaling high speed trains
complicated setups there are no agency
workers available to replace our members
this is one of the myths that grant
shaps is perpetuating because he has
problems with reality i think sometimes
there are no agency workers coming here
to work today there is a complete
lockdown of the railway on london
underground and the only people that are
working are managers that have been
trained up in a couple of hours to take
this forward as it happens the managers
union is balloting from yesterday as
well because they're facing exactly the
same problems so we think the problems
on the railway are going to escalate
uh as left are going to be in the valley
soon i think united are going to ballot
so the problems are getting worse and
worse and so the government has got to
to deal with that but there are no
agency workers here there's nobody
crossing our picket line
i understand that mr lynch and that's
certainly the case today but you know
will it still be the case if after this
week you still get nowhere with the
negotiations the government is saying
that they are going to bring in agency
workers my question to you is i'm
guessing that your some of your members
will still stay on the picket lines what
will they do if agency workers try to
cross those picket lines
well we will picket them what do you
think we'll do we run a picket line and
we'll ask them not to go to work do you
not know how to pick it up they do
anyway
i very much know how a picket line works
i'm much older than i look uh mr lynch
uh what will we what will picketing
involve
well you can see what picketing involves
i can't believe this line of questioning
pick it in is standing outside the
workplace to try and encourage people
who want to go to work
not to go to work
what else do you think it involves and
what if they want
well i just wondered what else it might
involve because i very well remember uh
the picket lines of the 90s where are
you going with your mr lynch
i'm asking you what your members would
do mr
[Music]
real uh no misfortune i'm sorry if you
feel the need to ridicule me but i'm
just asking you what you expect your
members are your questions your agency
works
for the nonsense
pick it as effectively as we can
and what does
you won't stop agency workers crossing
the picket line
we will try to stop agency workers
crossing the picket line by asking them
not to go to work what is it you're
suggesting women if they
i'm just asking you to try to clarify
for the benefits of the british public
we're being clarified
mr lynch i'm just trying to clarify
exactly what you're saying you're trying
to declare it as politely
i'm thank you for uh i'm replying to you
the question what we will okay
i've answered the question about six
times
if there are people trying to talk about
my satisfaction somehow we asked them
not to questions
i'm asking questions on behalf of my
viewers this morning mr lynch i'm very
sorry if you find it offensive well you
seem to have got lost in your voice
no i haven't
well perhaps i could just ask it just
once more see how you feel about it if
agency workers want to cross the picket
lines so that people can go about their
work and their business and travel
around the country your members will ask
them not to cross if they continue to
want to cross then you will allow them
to do so yes or no
we won't allow them to do so it's up to
them whether they do so or not we will
ask them
under the laws of this land not to cross
the picket line and not to be strike
breakers but if if agency workers think
they can go into a signaling centre or
operate a train
they're going to have a bit of a problem
aren't they so what do you think these
agency workers going to do when they
report and have across the picket line
they're not trained to do the work uh
because it's probably illegal for them
probably illegal for them to attempt to
just one final question
you've got a very busy day you've got a
very busy day ahead of you so let me
just ask you one final question if the
three strikes of this week do not amount
to a 7.1
pay rise offer being offered to your
members
will you go on strike again
yes we will go on strike again if we
don't get a settlement to the to the
issues so after this phase of action we
will review the situation
we'll look at where the negotiating
position is we'll continue to talk to
the companies
every opportunity and if we need to take
into further industrial action
that's what we'll do
it's an absolute pleasure to talk to you
mr lynch this morning thank you so much
for joining us hopefully we can chat in
person sometime very soon thank you uh
tamara's here hi tomorrow hi kay um what
an interview um the rmt say that their
members have not had a pay rise in three
years they also point out that um you
know their their argument is that the
government are planning a wave of
compulsory redundancies that they say
that has not been ruled out although
grant shap says they'll all be voluntary
and they're worried about ticket offices
closing about safety implications of
having fewer workers and that they want
to take a stand and i thought he was
tacitly encouraging others to do so too
he said other public sector unions
should be campaigning on the issues so
um the idea of a summer of discontent
really being raised there i think if
others follow suit okay let's bring in
chief exec of ryan and michael o'leary a
very different problem for you uh mr
o'leary but nevertheless huge problems
uh with the airlines what's the
situation this morning
good morning kate uh enjoyed your last
interview well done uh situation is not
huge chaos uh there is undoubtedly
problems particularly at a number of uk
airports most notably manchester
heathrow and gatwick uh where the either
the airport security or the baggage
handling providers are short staffed
that is causing pinch points but it's
important to keep some context here 1995
of all flights are getting away they are
delayed by atc and airport and handling
delays but they are getting away people
are getting to their destinations some
airlines are cancelling a small
proportion of their flights between five
and ten percent which is deeply
regrettable but this is one of the uh
the byproducts of the struggle to
recover smoothly from two years of code
lockdowns and government mismanagement
over there
uh we spoke to uh the government
minister yesterday you say it's to do
with brexit he says that's absolute
nonsense
it's not that completely do with brexit
i mean an awful lot of these pinch
points would be uh resolved very quickly
and very rapidly if we could bring in
european workers to do the jobs that
frankly people in the uk are not
applying for and don't want to do
this has always been the way the uk has
uh provided our uh man that staff is
transport industry uh and it is the way
forward if the and if we can't
attract people to do those jobs like
baggage handling like security at the
airport we're going to have to bring in
workers whether it's from ireland or
from the continental europe to do them
and brexit is one of the big bug bears
in the system it has introduced enormous
uh labor market in flexibility in the uk
and there are hundreds of thousands of
jobs in the uk that frankly british
workers don't want to do
um okay how long do you see the problem
continuing for
i think this problem is are going to
continue particularly at those airports
like that we can heat throw right
throughout the summer i mean it would be
worse at weekends it would be better
during the week uh
there are less problems at airports like
stan said ryanair is operating a full
schedule where fully staffed with pilots
and camper group but even we last
weekend suffered 24 of our flights were
delayed by air traffic control delays
another 15 of fights were delayed by
airport and handling uh
delays so i think it is going to be a
struggle through the summer the airlines
uh the uk airlines ba easyjet tui
ryanair and others we will get 1995
percent of but well right here we get
nearly 100 of our people to their
destinations i will be with delays but
it will be a less than satisfactory
experience and this problem will not be
resolved until we start
allowing european workers to come in and
do the jobs that frankly uk people no
longer wish to do
the government says it's the airline
industry's fault nothing to do with them
they gave you loads of money during
covert
it's the government's response to
everything look if this government
couldn't run a sweet shop uh i think in
grant shop says abe demonstrated that
this morning the airlines ryanair we're
fully staffed we're not cancelling any
flights we expect to run a food chain so
in fact we added 200 extra flights
yesterday for the remainder of june and
the early part of july to rescue
pastures whose flights have been
disrupted by cancellations being made by
other airlines and the problem here is
not one of the airlines making you've
had this government we've been locked up
for two years they introduced their
bogus traffic light system that never
made any sense and never worked during
coleman just as we were emerging out and
cope with the omicron variant and we
were locked down again over christmas as
we emerge out of christmas we're
beginning to recruit again and then the
russian invades ukraine and then the
problem here that the government
believes the problem is the airlines
look the airlines want to fly passengers
to their destinations in reiner's case
we're fully staffed up stansted and many
of our other airports in the uk are
doing a great job but we are hide bound
and hamstrung by a government that he's
so desperate to show that brings it has
been a success when it's been an abject
failure will not allow us to bring
european workers to these jobs
[Applause]
out of time mr leary good to talk to you
as always thank you for joining us on
the program have a great day
thank you you too thanks very much
indeed if you've only just uh joined us
my goodness me have you missed some
testy interviews this morning the
government minister accusing me of
wanting to take the government uh the
country back into the 1970s and i can't
even begin to tell you what the unions
were saying stay tuned and find out
[Music]